Now, what we're going to do is
build a forest model in Ultrix,
interpret the results,
and validate the model.
Now we've already created
samples of 70% for
the estimation sample, and
30% for the validation sample.
So let's bring in a force model and
configure it.
So we can find this force model tool
within the predictive category.
The first thing we're going to do,
just like all the other models
is simply name the model.
So I'm going to call this FM, for Forest
Model, under score transportation,
since that's what we're
trying to predict.
The next thing we're going to do is
select what is my target variable,
which is going to be the mode,
and then lastly what are my different
possible predictor variables?
So gender, age, marital status and
drive distance in miles.
And so far this is exactly
the same thing that we've done in
all the previous models
up to this point.
Now what are some of
the different options?
The first option is
the option rate below,
which is the number of trees to use.
So remember that we have
a force model here,
which is an ensemble of decision trees.
And even with the logo, you can see
that it's many different trees,
as compared to a decision tree,
which is one single tree.
This option right here
is to choose how many
of these individual decision trees
that we want to actually make.
So this can be 300, it can be 200,
it can be 5, it can be a thousand,
whatever you so choose.
Typically, we leave it at default,
which is 500,
then we go back and we change this
based off of some of the results that
we're going to review in the future.
The other options could be seen in
the model customization options.
What is the minimum number of
records allowed in a tree node?
So just like before, the smaller number
the more splits that are going to occur.
Now, the last two configuration options
revolve around a concept called
bootstrapping, which you can read
more about in the readings notes.
This is a more advanced technique and
for the purpose of this course,
we're going to keep these values and
options at the default places.
So, I'm going to bring a browse tool
after these are our report output
there's no interactive result for
this model.
So I'm going to run this, and
then I'm going to allow you to go and
learn a little bit of what you're
going to be looking for in the results,
in the next session.
Then we're going to come back and
actually view the results
from this model.